the first order of business is that well
I give this usually this is sort of
about order disorder so I have a little
questionnaire basically as to which has
the most order say you have five chairs
in a room which you could imagine these
five chairs you could stack them on top
of each other that's part one you could
line them up in a row like they are now
that's option to you could put them in a
circle that's option three you could put
two chairs three chairs on the bottom
and put two chairs on the top sort of
like a wall that's option for you could
put them in the room like the numbers
five on a dice like our died that's just
putting around the room like a pattern
of five an option six is random that's
just put them anywhere so I'll try to
pass this around you can make an X or s
check if you don't like X's whichever
one you think has the most order try to
put the check down there and we'll see
what happens okay so to get to this
start here I have an outline somewhere I
can find it or not here so this is
measuring discrete symmetry extended and
it's a continuation sort of of last
year's talk but it won't have well it's
only one section that's basically
extended from that however this is sort
of what you might call to search for
energy and that's like some a synonym or
another name for order basically so this
was started by HT Odom
is a Florida researcher who worked with
wetlands and so on and they came up with
an idea of measuring order they sort of
what he called energy something like
something emerging out of energy that's
built up over the past and they have 20
pages of tables so as far as connecting
to the real world you can look at those
20 pages of tables and it has the energy
of almost anything like sand or cogs or
whatever you might think of like people
how much does it energy does it take to
make a PhD person versus just someone
who graduates from grade school and so
on like that so that's one way of trying
to measure this there's like four
different ways of trying to measure this
sort of unknown quantity called energy
there was an Italian name jian antoni
who well first of all Adam considered an
equation was transforming etimes energy
equals energy so they're sort of like
transformer tease a scaling factor that
goes from energy to this unknown order
thing called energy and in Italian in
jenandtony suggested trying to factor
this into a generative component in a
dissipative component so I gave one talk
on that at the Florida talks on Lego
blocks where the generative component is
measured with symmetry like they did
last year and the dissipative component
is measured by how many sides of the
Lego blocks are used up so you have like
twenty twenty Lego blocks you can put
them together and make a rectangle using
up a certain number of sides in doing
that so you can count that and that's
basically the dissipative so the actual
quantity emerging
energy is based on the product of that
so if you just put a lot of blocks
around the room in a symmetric pattern
like the five pattern you will have a
lot of generative symmetry but you won't
have very much dissipative symmetry and
people wouldn't want to like live there
because there's no walls or anything so
essentially if you make the product of
these two you get some idea of what
people actually work with Anna there's a
paper on that in this in my book which
is called ah let's see somewhere here
it's called conflict in history there's
something called architecture case study
and transformative factorization and you
find that for the components that are
used in architecture such as walls and
pillars and so forth there's like a
local maximum of of this quantity
transformative emer G and so you have
think things like a wall or empty
rectangle or a pillar or something like
that we'll have local maximum of that
quantity and you can read about that in
this book which if you want to buy it as
fifteen dollars but anyway it's just one
little article out of that but anyway
the last year I tried to go at this
thing without having to measure this
quite difficult to see to count how many
sides are used up with the Lego blocks
like if you make a castle or something
like that it's difficult to count up how
many sides are actually used up when
they're put together so I just there's a
general way of doing this thing which I
called simplexity which is you can
calculate the total amount of symmetry
and just take that- how much that the
structure actually has whatever it is
and then you multiply that times the
symmetry has measured that I did last
year which is based on counting the
number of equal distances between pairs
of points okay so this is jumping around
a little bit but the question is to try
to explain why you need this quantity
energy or something and essentially you
can look at thermodynamics you find that
up this is from a talk called energy to
entropy to energy you find that people
thought that energy would measure sort
of how much pep something has the one
they started studying the equations they
found out that essentially oh boy you
could have different things that have
the same energy but they have different
amount of pep so to speak so the two two
cases here on the top as long as PV is
constant the energy will stay the same
because PD is dependent on the
temperature and the temperature basic
determines the temperature according to
the ideal gas law and how that will stay
the same as long as PV is constant so
you can make the volume 1 16th is big
and the pressure 16 times bigger and
this will have the same these two things
will have the same energy but this one
will have a lot more pep that will
bounce back basically so the
thermodynamics people brought in this
new idea called energy that's supposed
to measure how tired the energy is so
even today people don't use the
talk about they say I have a lot of
energy and not that I have not very much
entropy today or something like that huh
anyway so you can do these PV diagrams
and essentially the entropy is going up
as you get towards the large volume down
here entropy is going up or the disorder
so people thought that well we have the
answer this is the way we can measure
order versus disorder just calculate the
entropy and that will tell us whether we
have a lot of order or not however that
basically so this is the second one so
there is something called a sack or
petrol to entropy and essentially you
can play the same game the sack court
this is a formula for the Sacko tetrode
entropy Hannah this is the mass of the
quantity that's in the ideal gas law so
that's taken to the three halves power
and V appears to the first power so you
can do the same game if you are increase
the mass by 16 by a factor of 16 that's
like going from hydrogen to oxygen as
your gas and you take your volume down
by a factor of 64 then this quantity
will come out to be the same and that
means that the sack quartet road entropy
is the same and furthermore because of
the ideal gas law the temperature will
be the same because pv will be the same
so therefore you have a case where you
have the same the same energy and the
same entropy but you have a different
amount of order so most people would say
that I
sort of more muscular mullet molecules
of gas that are 6 x 16 x is heavier and
the volume is much less most people
would say this has more order than this
so this shows that you can't use entropy
by itself to measure order a disorder
similar to the problem that people had
with energy and entropy there's the same
problem with measuring order and
disorder versus entropy well any
questions on that well because it's
compressed into more space for example
if these were Ebola patients or
something you'd much rather have them in
say one room rather than all over the
whole city or something like that so
well I don't know did the list go around
of the poll about which has the most
order so let's see actually done this
and now people have come out with all
different ones but it looks like the
most popular one we're stacked on top of
each other and like the five on the dice
and one of them said random so as we'll
see there are sort of reasons for
choosing each one of these like in the
case of random which is sort of like
Bruce Lee de i forget what his statement
was about the best thing is nothing or
something like that but anyway if you
look at a look at the distribution of
distances random everything will be one
only there's only one distance of each
type so to that extent ah the density is
like a straight line which is in some
sense very ordered but anyway going
ahead with the talk here so any
questions about this this is kind of
hard to follow at first but uh it's what
it's basically telling us is that you
can't just get by
with order as entropy versus order
versus disorder that you have to look
for something else so well I'll try to
show this chart this is from a book the
time is coming along here yes we still
have some time this is from a book by
Arthur am young and do anything to make
that noise but anyway the he has tried
to develop things into different
kingdoms depending upon well what I
claim is it sort of like based on order
so it goes out from a very small scale
like light versus nuclear energy atomic
chemical sort of vegetable growth and
into animals and Dominion so anyway my
goal was to try to somehow in terms of
energy thinking that it could be related
to building well emergy is sort of like
energy quality so as you go to these
more complicated atoms like from oxygen
from helium or hydrogen to to say oxygen
you're getting more order in in the
nucleus so and to that extent this would
be like some measure of energy as you go
along here or transformative and it
scales up also so to talk go with what
the actual talk was about so anyway
there's a question of whether you can
take this out of the real world into a
math world and I found that you could
actually do this by looking at these
functions f of X equals one-half x 2
plus sign of 2 pi K X it turns out that
if you measure the energy of these
things in
terms of in terms of the norm the two
norm basically squared they are the
different cycles all have the same
energy and furthermore it will turn out
they have exactly the same entropy so
these are functions that have exactly
the same energy you might say and the
same Shannon entropy all of these
dependent no matter how many cycles you
put in but the Fisher information goes
up the Fisher information is defined as
see if we can get it down here is
defined as
that's on the top of the screen there
that's the integral of the derivative
squared divided by the probability
anyway it sort of measures how much the
gradients are so this is somewhat
comparison or comparable to the Lego
blocks that is to say you can use the
amount of gradients to sort of measure
how much how many surfaces are used up
if you imagine SI two particles that are
defined as gaussians and you gradually
move them together the gradients between
them will get used up similar to the
Lego blocks sides of the Lego blocks so
all the time is up well anyway huh let
me at least try to show the final result
here of this thing so you can imagine
nine Gaussian pair pulses and if you
combine them together that fissure
information will actually go down to a
minimum because the gradients get used
up but if you keep going and decrease
the separation distance 20 the gradients
will go back up and the fish or
information will go up to exactly the
same distribution or the same value it
had over here so this is one way to
define energy basically as by the
minimum Fisher information or the
negative of the Fisher information is
similar to the leg or bought Lego block
study